monsieur le premier ministre
bonjour bonjour pour commencer merci de
nous accorder cette interview exclusive
c'est bien normal vous savez le pays
traverse une période de crise je
voudrais que les français me fasse
confiance fasse confiance au ministre et
fasse confiance au président de l'afic
et pour cela je voudrais pas l'avis du
recteur première embauche non mais très
calme alors c'est bien celui-ci est
alors venu on va être sérieux deux
secondes j'ai lu sur le blog de jean
marc morandini
à ce qu'il paraît y en a un qui veut pas
s'attaquer dans les villes un peu le
vide à matignon est fait pas l'hypocrite
j'ai lu à ce qu'il paraît que face à
kernilis de l'intérieur c'est vrai ou
pas balancer des gens ils veulent savoir
c'est vrai que je ne vois pas pourquoi
je mentirais aux français elle aurait
presque man dire c'est pas bien pas vrai
les ko je pense qu'on s'éloigne du débat
ça s'est très bien passé mon domaine
allez y posez moi vos questions afin
d'établir un bilan au bout de cette
première année vous avez investi le
poste de premier ministre
j'aimerais vous poser trois questions
très clair comment bien soigné un herpès
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à un joli
quincy construit ma question
beurrer com
on se fait manger tout cas j'ai beaucoup
de mal à me faire comprendre les
français d'accord cette mascarade est
trop dure et moi j'en ai marre
en plus maintenant vous êtes en cheval
ça n'a aucun sens si les français
veulent s'informer vaut mieux pas qu'ils
regardent la télévision tout de suite
les ch'tis bienvenue au club
une mission commune